في محيط بخموت اطار المعارك الطحنه وجنود
الاوكرانيون ينتظرون الهجوم الروسي المقبل
في الوقت الذي تؤكد فيه قياده الجيش ان
الوضع متوتر جدا يصد الجنود محاولات
التوغل بشق الانفس
يمرون على هذه الطريق بين الاشجار لكننا
لا نسمح لهم بالتقدم الى هنا يتراجعون ثم
يزحفون ناحيتنا في الثانيه صباحا وفي
العاشره وحتى في الظهيره لكن نصدهم
داخل المدينه الوضع ذاته تتكرر العمليات
العسكريه للجيش الروسي ومقاتلي مجموعه
فاغنر مثل بعد هجوم المشاه يستخدم
المدفعيه لمهاجمه مواقعنا حاولوا اختراقنا
باستخدام عمود من الدبابات اختاروا مسارا
معينا لكننا استطعنا ايقافه بفضل الالغام
وضع المدنيين ليس افضل حالا يعيشون في
البرد ويعانون من انقطاع الاتصال ببقيه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المياه متجمده نستلقي تحت ثلاث بطانيات
واكثر لكنني لن اغادر بيتي من سيقبل بنا
في مكان اخر
ابنتي كانت تعيش قرب بخموت لم اسمع اي خبر
عنها منذ شهر لا اعلم هل هي حيه ام لا
ليست لدينا شبكه اتصالات
دمرت المعارك جزءا من مدينه بخمود حيث كان
يعيش سبعون الف شخص وتحاول القوه الروسيه
السيطره على المدينه ذات الاهميه في اقليم
دومباس